welcome back to part three of learning
C++ so we're gonna get right into it I'm
gonna teach you start teaching about
flow control and once I get through a
couple of these we'll do a little
project I'm gonna open up our main dot
CPP again from the command line like
we've kind of been doing and here's
where we left off last time I'm just
gonna go ahead and get rid of all this
we don't need this and I just want to
show you some basic FL so the syntax of
an FLV is starts with an if and then
parenthesis of what you want to execute
right before it potentially enters this
block and now I'm going to over explain
this so that you understand everything
about what happens in this parentheses
before potentially going into this block
it evaluates whatever is in these
parentheses if it evaluates to true it
goes into this block if it evaluates to
false it skips past this block and goes
on and that's where the else comes in so
I will just say it executes whatever's
in here value is true or false
ultimately but it's important to know
that you can just put commands in here
too like if I want to put a C out in
here and have it say something it will
as it executes this block it'll it'll
just spit out this so you know to the
console so you can you can literally put
in anything here it's just a bit of code
that executes like that but usually what
you want to do is you want to put some
kind of evaluation in here that decides
whether it goes into the block or not so
you might have somewhere earlier in your
code an integer
just called a thingy and maybe it's
equal to 10 and maybe it changes for
some reason or another and you want to
check down further what it is so you
would say thingy
now this equals equals is a comparison
operator of an exact equality the single
one is an assignment and now like I said
this does just execute the code so a
really common error is to just put a
plain old equals here and
think that it's gonna compare but it's
not comparing it is assigning so this
will just be confused this will always
evaluate to true no matter what thing he
was originally even if it was 20 or 210
this would just assign it to ten and
then evaluate to true because well zero
is always false anything else
is true so no matter what this evaluates
to as long as it's not zero it'll be
true so that's just a common error there
but really what we might want to do is
say if it's less than or equal to some
certain thing who knows what it could be
depending on what we're doing
we'll do some real examples later and
you can use or to chain it with other
things so maybe you want some more
ranges to consider or greater than 500
so this would be a scenario where it
would enter the block if it's less than
or equal to 123 or if it's greater than
500 which means there's a dead range
here of 124 to 499 where it would not
enter the block so that's just an
example of how you can control it and
maybe if it's in that dead range you
want to do something else so you do an
else--if but if it's exactly I don't
know
255 and then you want to do something
specific so that would be a case there
and if it ends up being something else
you go to this these do short-circuit so
once it hits one of these it stops
executing the rest and skips over so
that's the basics of if else if you want
to get further with this you want to
study these comparison operators less
than greater than less than equal
greater than equal equals not equals and
then there's or just two of those bars
and there's and so those are the main
things you can use and you can chain
them together as you need sometimes
you'll see really giant checks that
might span multiple lines
and you can use parentheses to section
them off some it can do stuff like this
or it will check this full analysis here
and see if that's true or false and then
do the end next so you can kind of
control the order to this here would be
it would evaluate this one see if it
gets true or not if this ends up being
false it it's not even gonna check over
here but if this ends up being true then
it keeps going with the and and checks
later I'll see you in the next video
thank you for watching